[Musica]
molti di voi si staranno chiedendo che
cosa c'è in questa scatola bene quello
che c'è in questa scatola
lo scopriremo alla fine ora vorrei
partire che cosa c'è fuori per la
scatola thinking out box però per
introdurre un argomento sul pensiero
laterale la percezione devo iniziare a
testare come se temesse
ok la prima cosa che vedremo su pensiero
laterale e la percezione e la percezione
è molto importante perché ci permette di
partire da un obiettivo e facciamo un
esperimento insieme vi chiedo di alzarvi
tutti e ora vediamo il cambio di
percezione
vi chiedo la persona a fianco quando vi
darò il via vi presenterete come se in
contrasto è un vecchio amico che lo
incontrate da vent'anni via
ok ok molto bene adesso cambiamo la
persona e ci presentiamo come se
incontrassimo la persona più famosa
importante che vorremmo incontrare la
nostra vita
che tipo di l'impatto sarebbe
benissimo e adesso vorrei lanciarvi una
sfida vediamo quanto siete in grado ed
ora debon usa una tecnica che si chiama
provocativo brescia ho la mia provoca
operation adesso è iniziamo dalla fine
vorrei quando terol via di fare
l'applauso di conclusione del mio
discorso come se avesse partecipato al
miglior discorso con eduardo boni più
grandi pensatori 123 ma non troppo buone
[Applauso]
ok grafica adesso vi invito a sedervi e
cerchiamo di guadagnare almeno una parte
di questo applauso
il punto centrale del pensiero laterale
ed è buono dice poco eccitante parlare
del focus dell'obiettivo su cui vogliamo
tenere creatività ma è molto importante
ad esempio nella nasa stavano costruendo
avevamo bisogno di una penna che fosse
in grado di scrivere in assenza di
gravità
questa cosa chiaramente un problema
pensate agli astronauti qui andiamo
nello spazio e allora ha investito
decine di milioni di dollari per
costruire una penna che era in grado di
scrivere con differenti inclinazioni
ok a un certo punto i russi avremo lo
stesso problema
ma che cosa hanno fatto hanno cambiato
il focus diverso ha detto in che modo
potrei scrivere lo sta nello spazio
senza gravità hanno usato una matita per
cui il cambio di obiettivo spesso è già
generativo di creatività e questo è un
primo punto
in realtà le donne qui presenti che
convivono con un maschietto sanno che
una delle cose più difficili da far
cambiare in un uomo è fare in modo che
c'entri esattamente il buco nell'asse ok
e che cosa hanno inventato negli
autogrill hanno inventato una mosca da
mettere lì così maschietti quando
arrivano il loro idrante indirizzano
l'obiettivo e guarda caso sono diminuite
le quantità
straborda menti perché il focus era
orientato invece di dire palla dentro
tutte le regole eccetera cambiare il
focus per cui il primo punto è il focus
il secondo punto è il pensiero laterale
debbono ha formalizzato al pensiero
laterale e la formalizzato però partendo
dal presupposto il cervello non è fatto
per essere creativo e buona parte i
presenti dicono allora sono nel posto
giusto
il cervello è fatto per cercare schemi
che funzionano
ok se adesso faccio ta ta ta ta ta ta
perché il cervello chiude gli schemi
quando impara guidare l'automobile ci
metto un po e poi o degli automatismi
che mi permettono poi di non sbagliare
più
ok qualcuno vi sarà capitato invece ho
cambiato l'automobile con cambio manuale
a quello automatico e il primo momento è
stato un po un problema per cui gli
schemi ci servono fanno risparmiare al
cervello una quantità di energia
pazzesca ma per la creatività dobbiamo
uscire dagli schemi e per uscire de bono
dice per stimolare il pensiero laterale
dobbiamo usare degli stimoli che
permettano di uscire dallo schema questa
formalizzazione però importante non è
crisi vene la follia è usare uno stimolo
esterno che ci faccia uscire dal
pensiero lineare ma che poi dà un'idea
logica posteriore ad esempio debbono fa
un esempio per far capire nel mondo
della creatività
non dobbiamo pensare tanto la
competizione con le altre aziende da tre
organizzazioni lui dice dobbiamo pensare
alla spedizione cioè fare gara a sè e
per spiegare questo siccome ha trovato
delle correlazioni tra umorismo e
creatività racconta una storiella sono
due amici uno è un saputello tutto
preparato perfettino e l'altra un po più
spartano più diciamo alla mano stava
andando in cammino in montagna a un
certo punto incontrano un grizzly
grizzly è molto pericoloso per l'uomo
perché in grado con una zampata di
ucciderlo e purtroppo giudizi
inizia a correre verso di loro a quel
punto il saputello dice arriva il
grizzly non fosse ancora più veloce
grezzi siano finite quello meno
saputello si piega inizia a togliere gli
scarponcini tira fuori dallo zaino le
scarpe da tennis iniziale tedesca per
tennis l'amico lo guarda e dice guarda i
crisi ricorda 60 chilometri all'ora
tu come uomo al massimo 35 40 al massimo
guadagnerai due o tre metri prima che ti
colpisca che ti prende quindi c'e ma a
me non interessa ancora il più veloce di
crisi ma più veloce di te
il cambio di prospettiva e il pensiero
laterale poi fa diventare logica
posteriore una soluzione
tante volte ci è capitato di abbiamo
trovato una soluzione che dopo diciamo
che stupido non me ne ero proprio
accorto ecco questo è usare degli
strumenti deliberati per per forzare la
mente a uscire dagli schemi perché non è
creativa ma purtroppo il pensiero a
teheran non basta anche i colleghi
precedenti ha detto non solo dei due
emisferi
ma la creativi tempo cosa di completo
infatti io stesso molti anni fa ho
coniato un termine che creatività che
andare oltre a semplici creatività e
nello specifico il pensiero parallelo
personalmente di buono è famoso per il
pensiero laterale questo è il costrutto
più importante che lui ci ha donato
nello specifico lui dice mi ha
raccontato sta storia che poi non ho più
raccontato negli ultimi 20 anni per cui
la socializza con voi però non l'hanno
la racconta più su come funziona il
cervello
lui dice i pescatori dei paesi tropicali
hanno scoperto che l'ostrica crea la
perla la perla da vostri capi e naturale
più a valore e hanno scoperto che
legandole tutte insieme buttandola in
acqua l'ostrica fa il suo tempo e cresce
ma la cosa interessante
pensate tornano dopo un anno ostrica
mollusco si può muovere un metro 2 per
cui potrebbe essere a 300 400 metri di
distanza
che cosa accade le ostriche sono due o
tre metri da dove le ha lasciate secondo
voi cosa è successo
essendo tutte legate una tira di qui una
tiratina l'altra tira di qui e si rimane
esattamente fermi questo è quello che de
bona formalizzato sul pensiero tra gli
esseri umani gli esseri umani c'è quello
che cerca di essere creativo c'è quello
che di essere analitico quello che cerca
di valutare un idea se cerco di fare
tutto insieme
quello che io ottengo e bloccare la
creatività di innovazione del gruppo
ok non faccio riferimenti a contesti
politici che non si possono fare ma è un
bellissimo esempio di ostrica mento di
non riuscire a muoversi
ok andiamo avanti con un'applicazione
particolarmente di questo concetto che
la creatività in realtà è solo uno stile
di pensiero ma ce ne sono almeno altri 9
che ci aiutano per realizzare le cose
thomas edison diceva la creatività è un
per cento inspirazione 99 per cento
traspirazione fare le cose
imparare e questo è un punto molto
importante perché noi qui stiamo
condividendo moltissime idee ma le idee
da sole sono passive dobbiamo fare in
modo di farle diventare attive e per
questo approfondirò 45 schemi di
pensiero che possono aiutarci per
realizzare le nostre idee
il primo punto è legato alla capacità di
saper cogliere le idee tutti noi
vorremmo essere più creativi no io vi
dico lasciate perdere non diventate più
creativi infatti come steve jobs steve
jobs non era creativo steve jobs non era
un informatico
steve jobs è famoso per aver rubato idee
un po tutti
vi faccio due esempi primo le interfacce
grafiche andò in visita alla xerox parc
che facevano fotocopiatrici vide
interfacce grafiche chiese scusi ma che
ci fate con queste interfacce grafiche
loro dissero noi siamo un'azienda che fa
fotocopia non facciamo computer per cui
non lo so ci serve per questo lui prese
l'idea esagerò prese anche direttore
ricerca e sviluppo lo portò in apple
implemento questa idea la seconda idea
un capolavoro
dobbiamo lanciare un prodotto lanciano
l'ipod l'ipod era un brevetto scaduto
che lui ha preso da un ragazzotto che
aveva fatto 20 anni e purtroppo non ha
beccato una lira perché adesso di per
pagare il brevetto l'ha lanciato sul
mercato voi e cogliere il valore delle
idee
io ho creato un database di idee o più
di un miliardo idee raccolte in tutto il
mondo di successo imprenditoriale di
marketing e ed è impressionante quanto
idea ci sono per cui prendiamo le idee
dagli altri e miglioriamo le secondo
punto è come motivare la creatività
molto più importante il fuoco il perché
e questo è fondamentale non tanto avere
idee io dico un buon perché vale mille
come diamo un buon motivo c'è una storia
divertente apollo 13 il behind film un
signore lo affitta con blockbuster c'è
un'azienda fallita che si chiamava
blockbuster affitta questo video tutto
contento si dimentica del video come
capita a tutti noi
dopo 60 giorni lo riporta e gli danno 30
dollari di multa si inviperisce e dice
faccio qualcosa di diverso per fargli
vedere a questi fetenti e crea netflix
netflix è nata così per la rabbia
molto spesso della motivazione rabbia
invidia odio passione amore sono le
chiavi di successo e noi abbiamo
spessissimo l'imprenditore imprenditore
o l'inventore sono due
diciamo personaggi che la motivazione di
smuove perché ci interessa questa parte
perché per realizzare qualcosa sia da
inventori che da imprenditore
pensate che tyson quello che ha creato
il l'aspirapolvere affatto 5.000
prototipi che non funzionavano ora
accettare 5.000 fallimenti notevole
thomas edison il suo collaboratore di
disse thomas
doveva inventare la lampadina abbiamo
fatto 10 mila fa di mente in modo di
amor colpo che di rispondere abbiamo
fatto 10 mila fallimenti sappiamo 10.000
modi di come non si fa una lampadina
ok la frustrazione dell'insuccesso è
molto legata alla motivazione per cui se
io la passione riesco a combattere ea
imparare ea non farmi scoraggiare da
questi elementi è ancora di più se io
sono molto creativo e un altro è molto
organizzato e inutile che io investa
tanto tempo a imparare a diventare molto
più organizzato non ce la faccio le mie
brain dominance sono troppo forti per
cui la storia ci insegna alleanza di
cervelli fatte come alleanza di cervelli
di persone che sono complementari a voi
la pensino magari valorial mente insieme
ma li compra rita complementarità la
storia dei successi è data da tantissime
persone che avevano stili complementare
e insieme a questa parte c'è la
comunicazione dell'idea è molto
importante saper comunicare l'idea alla
base si dice se io ho una banana e tu e
una banana ci scambiamo la banana
alla fine ognuno di noi andrà via con
una banana ma se io ho un'idea e tu hai
un'idea
quando andremo via avremo entrambi due
idee per cui condividere senza la paura
di farsi rubare idee particolarmente con
la nostra alleanza dei cervelli molti
successi imprenditoriali o dire sono
state su come le ho comunicate e come
gli ho sapute diciamo fare il marketing
dell'idea
ho iniziato dieci anni fa con philip
kotler demone un progetto che si chiama
marketing che è come avere creatività
per vendere le idee conta molto di più
saperla vendere e ora siamo arrivati a
aspettare
la domanda che cosa abbiamo nella
scatola ora chi indovina può mangiarne o
no che cosa abbiamo nella scatola quello
che abbiamo della scatola ed ultimo
punto con cui vi lascio che molto
importante come stile di pensiero
i creativi spesso ne pensano mille ma
non ne fanno il punto importante è il
pensiero pratico rendere concreta l'idea
che volete fare è imparare sbagliando
che per far vero meglio capire aprivano
la scatola è tirato fuori questa che è
una lampadina dell'idea ma per farvi non
meglio ancora capire che dovete agire e
non solo pensare
vi invito ad esso tutti quanti ad alzare
il culo ma concretamente perché sotto la
vostra sedia l'omessa uno per va in
omaggio fatelo
idee un antistress
l'obiettivo che vi chiedo sarà quello
fra poco avremo la pausa e quando sarete
insieme
condividete le vostre idee le vostre
passioni e create le vostre alleanze di
cervello grazie
[Applauso]